[Applause]
the people of east Mosul find themselves
on the front line their neighborhoods
are bullets strewn and barricaded with
snipers on the rooftops and bodies on
the ground it's on there's no food here
no water or power although the odd
soldier hands over supplies so residents
must make a momentous decision do they
stay for their lives
[Applause]
are you going to leave
it's understandable Isis is firing at
them and the Iraqi army fears some
civilians
maybe suicide bombers so all 18 members
of the Achmed family are staying tuned I
believe necesitamos 7:00 a.m. oh no - in
a place where fear is the only constant
tens of thousands have decided to go and
we saw them walking out of this
lacerated city with weary legs and
shattered nerves supported on old carts
and wheelbarrows their only protection
white flags tied to sticks and broom
handles
this is Gok jolly village 1,500 meters
from the front line and for many it has
come to symbolize salvation
Achmed Abbasi and his family left their
home at 5 a.m. and he told me he
surprised to be alive something worth
telling - my father arrived at important
since the alcohol damn near took button
allows them to throw humanoid the Abbas
ease and others have made their escape
but no one knows when there were turn
for the time being
they'll try to make a new home in a fast
expanding refuge for some this dusty
village signifies the end to American
volunteers run a first aid station here
and we watched as they try to keep the
Hassan family alive
four-year-old may add was buried under
cement when their house was hit by a
mortar and it was an assault she would
not survive the medics worked hard to
keep her sister there brother
Yahya worked on may its mother and
father overwhelmed it didn't stop there
the next patient was an 11 year old girl
called a beer jazzing ahmed she was shot
through the right lung as she tried to
escape
and there was nothing these first aiders
could do to help she was wrapped up in a
blanket and her father took her to the
side where he and a biers brother began
to grieve later I asked one of the
medics a former machinist from San Diego
how he coped there's been a few times
where I start to break down in the
middle of treatment or you can tell one
of our guys starts to lose it but we
kind of quickly snap back in those
refugees who make it out of Mosul aren't
guaranteed their freedom before they
reach the camps the men are screened
Iraqi intelligence officers here looking
for members of is the threat from within
[Music]
the men and the women have been strictly
segregated and the women haven't been
asked any questions at all then
subjected to a pretty basic a pretty
four country interrogation process the
names will get checked against the
computer as well so far that's it later
several men were isolated then taken to
the office of a former auto shop of the
highway officers told us they'll be
taken for further questioning eventually
Achmed Abbasi and his family made it to
the cap although they had to walk two
kilometres to find themselves a tent
many more people are expected in fact
this place has doubled in size over the
past two weeks but the fact they made it
is something of a success John sparks
Sky News in northern Iraq
you